[Music]
in fighting off aliens knees submitted
by chicken butt watching but an Arizona
ranch owner tired of fighting off aliens
puts it up for sale that's what he put
in his ad
I'm tired of fine because god damn
Martian it could be illegal aliens the
[ __ ] is a Mexico Marvin the Martian what
is he did Marvin the Martian Mexican no
I'm thinking about [ __ ] what's his
name alpha alpha from Power Rangers he's
a [ __ ] Mexican space guy he's an
alien though yeah he's a Mexican aliens
a robot he's a Mexican alien though he
just goes oh yeah yeah he doesn't have
an exit he's Mexican and Mexican get the
[ __ ] no it's the guy that works for sort
on he's good on the system the alien I
mean I don't the robot he was a robot
all he said was I AI promise hated alpha
every time he came on and started
panicking I'm like quit panicking you
panicking little [ __ ] it gave me so
much anxiety
what are you [ __ ] worrying about I
was so angry so Jon and Joyce Edmund so
Jon us okay psychiatric therapists enjoy
is an ex-fbi employee so they're the
owners of this ranch
purchased in 1996 in rave rainbow valley
arizona just outside of Phoenix it's not
so pleasant to live in yes the 10 acre
ranch used to take care of unwanted or
abused horses Oh what you want to do I
love Arizona but yeah very close they
have a 3,400 square-foot house and an
in-ground pool and so now they are
selling it for 5 million after the
initial price of 1.7 million with
national exposure because they are just
tired of dealing with these aliens over
the past 20 years they've been fighting
off these aliens are dealing with them
oh how do they fight them off yeah you
probably karate
they claim that they've been abducted
multiple times and again they're saying
that immediately when they moved in they
started witnessing weird things
happening well it's cheers oh [ __ ] how
did you break it yeah so immediately
when they moved in weird things started
happening the previous owner had left
all their furniture in the house and so
John called the real estate John called
the real estate agent to have it moved
and so they told him that it would be
moved within the next few hours so he
left and then he came back later that
day and he found all the furniture
thrown into the pool so he was pissed so
he called the real estate agent back and
he was like why like why would you do
this or who did this or whatever and
then the agent said that the previous
owners told him that they thought he did
it that John Donne's did office and so
they were pissed too they were just like
well we're leaving it here so both sides
are like who the [ __ ] put all this stuff
from the house into the pool they're
pranking each other yeah loved one and
then a few days later after they
moved in a rough-looking man with a
machete came up to the house
danny trejo and he told John that he
lived at the ranch and then John told
him to leave him he thought he was just
some crazy guy nearby and then that's
when the man told him you are going to
wish I was here you are really going to
be sorry there are monsters on this
property and I kill them and so John and
Joyce they started noticing strange orbs
and lights in the sky like over the
years of a bearded man with a machete
he's like the he's so here he's the he's
the Alien Hunter the rough looking man
the Alien Hunter apparently I gave him a
beard in my imagination yeah I'm a beard
he's kind of like a biker guy I picture
like five o'clock shadow I pictured
Casey Jones I pictured three hundred but
more hairier and like with a leather
vest and leather chaps with tassels with
and then because this is Southwest I'm
picturing a little bit of a cowboy vibe
here with a with a more turquoise kind
of jewelry and a little bit of the oh no
you don't agree okay but um yeah like
Indian Reservation yeah I kind of kind
of mixed then and he views a biker and a
renegade
you saying that he never saw that man
ever again
well cuz he didn't invite oh yeah cuz he
was like you're gonna be sorry
and so now John is I gosh it should have
got his calling card I just literally
picture these guys like the couple like
there's it's a Sunday morning
everything's fine he's cooking eggs and
they just start floating in the air
again there's something well they're
saying that they've experienced a lot of
a lot of moments in their memory that
are just gone like they don't remember
like they'll just all of a sudden be
like oh I like how did I get from here
to here like they'll forget and then
that's when they think like oh maybe I
got it
maybe there's maybe there are a couple
that plays the quaaludes game yeah maybe
she's a psychiatric therapist right what
if they're like taking drugs and stuff
yeah he is and she's an FBI former
employee yes sounds like a couple that
likes to [ __ ] do drugs maybe who
knows but this all like there's a lot of
stuff here so then John is describing
that he's seen these great aliens that
he calls them grades that there are
about 40 inches tall
large compound eyes similar to a fly
with snake-like skin cold to the touch
and that they appear in groups of three
and that they always invade their home
at nighttime um Joyce says that she has
been frequently attacked and molested by
them but she's unable to scream when
it's happening and that she'll find
puncture wounds and bruises on her skin
Wow I'm decided to buy weapons to
protect themselves and their horses and
their dogs because John has found his
horses mutilated with his with the eyes
and tongue removed and he lost three
Rottweilers who appeared to fight off
the graze and died despite not having
any visible injuries hmm so then John
this one time he said that he saw his
wife being abducted through a cone of
light hold you in there was an aircraft
outside and so he started shooting the
aircraft with with his ak-47 running we
left and they left her and then also if
the feeling like she's floating in the
air and the aircraft these are just
[Laughter]
focusing on just that affect me and
these aliens know I have to [ __ ] like
human style like why do I don't a lien
[ __ ] like mentally or like by staring at
her eyes or some [ __ ] or they're the one
thing you're right but you said that
she's gotten molested and she can't see
she's like mutilated and she don't know
where to put the dick because there's
puncture wounds all over her body so
they're trying to still figure it out
she's getting like I don't know anyways
moving on so then one time John a
stabbed one of the graves with a samurai
sword but why does he have a samurai
sword you know everyone has one come on
you know saying that every time he kills
one of these Gray's that they they just
disappear in in midair like they can't
he can't ever get any evidence of these
guys because then as soon as they die
they just disappear did he ever think
about setting up cameras in the house
around the house there was there was a
mention of that I forgot what it was but
they erased the footage because they
have the electromagnetic oh yeah yeah
yeah forgot through the grace yeah so
then um this one time that he did stab
one of the graves with the samurai sword
his sword still had a chunk of the alien
at the tip so he sent that over to being
analyzed by this man named William
Levengood so he's a crop circle
researcher and he says that the blood
did not match any animal or human and
that the skin was a part was animal
plant cross and I had never been seen
before and then shortly after he
analyzed the evidence here he stopped
communicating with John and he was
killed in a freak accident in his lab
and John says and then also the evidence
was it was missing like someone stole
the the skin that's gone that's the men
in black John says talking about the men
in black he said that the men in black
have visited him many times and they
make him uncomfortable to speak of these
things in public and also ghost
researchers have found an incredibly
high amount of magnetic activity on the
ranch so and so people were asking like
well why would you put up with this for
20 years like I know [ __ ] pretty much
he said quote I am extremely stubborn
both logically and rationally I have a
lot of money and time invested in this
property and many M animals housed here
but now he's selling it cuz now he's
just over it so much I think I think
it's a great way for a real estate like
like marketing it's like some people
have mad money they'll be like let's buy
it well it's been like a known property
worth a lot of these alien hunter people
they like hang out there know that
you've been interviewed a lot for like
different he should if there really are
aliens he should start making like a
make it into a hotel and be like get
your ass abducted by aliens here come
along to the alien ranch nobody like
someone died there's no [ __ ] I don't
know if it really is real you just sign
a liability waiver he looks like a tough
ass dude yeah so this is proof of some
of his injuries when he's fighting them
and then there's that's just his SAMCRO
days so he was being uh interviewed and
he claims that there is some proof that
some graves were popping up in the
background so I'm gonna play it during
an interview with Kerry Cassidy for
Project Camelot he ever to what John
believes his greys we're in the
background peering over his shoulder
take a look so yeah there's been a
tremendous amount of events that
happened during that period of time
hundreds yeah there's been a tremendous
amount I don't see [ __ ] take a dog's
tail yeah it's like barely anything but
this is like video proof oh these
stories are so good the way he says it
too like he sounds pretty convincing cuz
he's like I know this [ __ ] sounds crazy
but this should happen to me oh my god
it sounds so good I don't know I mean
how come all these alien things always
happen in like the southwest yeah like
is there just a amount of a tremendous
amount of radiation that helps people
hallucinate or some [ __ ] around there
like it ever happened in this like the
city city yeah I mean you never know
with but you'll hear like these kind of
stories in LA but there have been sounds
like Arizona New Mexico Colorado and
it's like some big-ass ranch ass area
yeah is that ever happens in Phoenix and
no one ever saw it but them yeah I wanna
I want a story were 50 people were like
yep we saw that [ __ ] grey alien yeah
that guy came over here he tried to take
my ball out of my sack like I forgot
where was it because Venezuela or
somewhere but there was a [ __ ] ton of
all these UFOs I just appeared I'm
nowhere in the night and then they're
like floating around there's like
multiple cell phone coverage of right
then and there coming out saying like
the military I mean even even I think it
was the FBI they released it like five
years ago or something like that they
had to release the the the public
records now you can see all the UFO like
records that they have it's been around
for a while but a fool like in the flesh
alien and
and I want to see like 50 people like I
want to see it alien at Disneyland you
know I mean like there's there's
definite proof there's there's all these
people that saw this [ __ ] undeniable
it's under night
on the log ride going like this and [ __ ]
and you know like I want to see that
[ __ ] well if we're playing with the idea
that it would be a real thing and they
actually do see the alien what if it's
the government trying to like wipe
everyone like men in black like who
knows like who knows how much of this is
really like it's it's it's a human being
in a costume or they'll be like oh 50
people like oh yeah so no it was just
this one experiment we were trying her
this new makeup really there's so many
excuses especially now that technology
has advanced so much and there's like
Photoshop and video editing like yeah I
think there could be solid proof then
we'll just forever deny it I wouldn't I
love the movie man in black
I hope there's aliens
[Music]